good morning from the ukrainian capital
kiev gunfire and explosions have been
heard here and in the second city of
kharkiv shortly after the russian
president vladimir putin authorized a
special military operation in ukraine's
donbass region and told the ukrainian
military to lay down their weapons and
go home
in a special televised address on
russian state tv mr putin said russia
had been left with no choice but to
defend itself against what he said were
threats from ukraine
this is what we know so far in moscow
vladimir putin announced the military
operation
just before 3 am uk time at the same
time an emergency meeting of the
security council was taking place in new
york
as president putin spoke before dawn big
explosions were heard on the outskirts
of kiev kharkiv odessa and other cities
across ukraine there are reports that
russian troops have landed in mariopol
and odessa they have not been confirmed
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
has declared martial law in ukraine and
told people to stay home
well since then we've had a series of
developments uh throughout the morning
air aid sirens have been heard here in
the capital kiev though we are told uh
they are tests at the moment in the
donetsk region russian-backed
separatists say they have launched what
they call massive strikes against
ukrainian forces
more recently the ukrainian military say
their air defense system shot down five
russian planes and one russian
helicopter in the luhansk region though
the russians have denied that that has
happened and in the uk the prime
minister boris johnson is expected to
convene that cobra committee meeting i
was talking about at a half past seven
this morning
let's listen back to that special
address on russian television by
vladimir putin in the early hours of
this morning
i decided to conduct a special military
operation
its goal is the protection of the people
who for eight years suffered from abuse
and genocide from the kiev regime
urge you to lay down arms immediately
and go home
i will explain
all servicemen of the ukrainian army who
comply with this requirement can freely
leave the area of military action and
return to their families
whoever would try to stop us and further
create threats to our country to our
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate and lead you
to such consequences that you have never
faced in your history
well a few hours ago ukraine's president
vladimir zelensky declared martial law
here and he urged citizens not to panic
as russia launched their military
strikes
let's take a look at what he said in a
video posted on his social media
channels
dear ukrainians
this morning president putin announced a
special military operation in the
donbass russia carried out strikes on
our military infrastructure on our
border guards explosions were heard in
many cities of ukraine we introduced
martial law throughout the state
a minute ago i had a conversation with
president biden the u.s is starting to
gather international support
today we need you each of you to be calm
if possible stay at home please we are
working the army is working the entire
security and defense sector of ukraine
is working
i the national security and defense
council the government will be in touch
soon i will be in touch again
do not panic we are strong we are ready
for everything and we will defeat
everyone because we are ukraine
glory to ukraine
zielinski talking to the people of
ukraine there western leaders have been
reacting
to what has happened this morning the
prime minister boris johnson he tweeted
this i am appalled by the horrific
events in ukraine and i have spoken to
president zielinski to discuss the next
steps
president putin has chosen a path of
bloodshed and destruction by launching
this unprovoked attack on ukraine the uk
and our allies will respond decisively
in the united states u.s president joe
biden said the prayers of the entire
world are with the people of ukraine as
they suffer an unprovoked and
unjustified attack by russian military
forces mr biden said president putin has
chosen a premeditated war that will
bring a catastrophic loss of life and
human suffering and that the world will
hold russia accountable
the u.s president says he will be
monitoring the situation from the white
house and will continue to get regular
updates from his national security team
he says he will meet with his g7
counterparts
in the morning
in europe european commission president
ursula von der lyon says in these dark
hours our thoughts are with ukraine and
the innocent women men and children as
they face this unprovoked attack and
fear for their lives
the ukrainian foreign minister dimitrio
kuleba has urged the world to act
immediately warning that the future of
europe and the world was at stake he's
called for devastating sanctions as he
put it on russia
now and for russia to be fully isolated
he also called for
more weapons equipment financial and
humanitarian assistance
for ukraine
the german chancellor olaf schultz said
russia must stop this military action
immediately
today he said we will coordinate closely
within the framework of the g7 nato and
the eu mr schultz added this is a
terrible day for ukraine and a dark day
for europe
so
let's have a look at the map the map
that shows uh the rebel-held areas of
donetsk and luhansk
there we are uh that's the center of all
this down in uh southeastern ukraine's
donbass region earlier this week russia
recognized the regions as independent
from ukraine and
signed friendship treaties with both of
them
ukraine considers them and
the un considers them temporally
occupied territories
but russia say they are theirs and
they annexed crimea
and
to the south of donetsk is mario pole
which lies outside of the rebel-held
area
but this morning reports of at least two
blasts have been heard
in that city so clearly uh
a lot of action going on down there
deborah haynes is uh
with me and so deborah i mean that we
could see there the map of
donetsk and a lot of action clearly
going on there and this was the
justification used by putin but just
give us
as you know it what is what is happening
in this country
well in yeah in terms of that
justification you heard president putin
talking about genocide which is just
completely false he's created this false
narrative to justify what he's done uh
saying that there's been like these
attacks in the east and that the
ukrainian government poses that threat
which is just not true and and in terms
of what
i'm just i do apologize i'm going to
we're just going to lose a guest as a
ukrainian mp i will come straight back
to you lestia vasilenko is a member of
the uk of the ukrainian parliament in
kiev and she can speak to us now and can
you just give us first of all your
reaction
to what is happening to your country
this morning
okay well first of all i'd like to say
that it's not separatist held areas or
whatever the terminology you were using
these are ukrainian territories which
are occupied today not by separatists
but by russian army irregular forces of
the russian military and also regular
russian military which has broken
ukrainian borders which is bombing
ukrainian airports and uh which is
literally marching on to kiev and other
cities so this must be very clear we're
not talking about any kind of civil war
or any hints at civil war literally
ukraine is at war a war which was
declared by russia at 5 00 a.m this
morning kiev time officially and uh 3
a.m uk time but also uh a war which has
started several hours before that when
the first shellings uh of eastern parts
of ukraine have started so uh i urge you
all please the media the international
community politicians to use the proper
language there are no separatists these
are russian military which are attacking
a sovereign independent country which is
merely fighting for the right to exist
absolutely and what do you
think that president putin
wants to achieve here
well it is clear he doesn't want ukraine
to exist as as is his either going to
destroy our country physically or he is
going to destroy us politically by
putting pressure now on the people
keeping the people in fear and making
sure that the politician like the
politicians like myself come into
parliament and vote for ridiculous
decisions uh saying that ukraine will
never be part of nato saying that
ukraine uh
admits that crimea is russian and
whatever other uh complete madness that
he has in his mind in order to rebuild
his russian empire and this is the crazy
world that we live in today just this
morning i've been up since uh 5 30 a.m
uh time and at 7am i was already in the
rada prepared to vote for the martial
law and we voted the martial law in
ukraine is in a state of war a war
declared by russia on ukraine and which
started back in 2014 with russian
aggression